hey what is up guys of kabhi HD here and
it's about that time of year again to
talk about one of the most anticipated
smartphones coming up for this year in
2015 and that would be the HTC One m9 so
the HTC One m8 that came out last year
is already one of the most well-liked
phones of 2014 and it's also one of the
most popular I gave it an award in my
smartphone awards 2014 and it continued
to drive the conversation about build
quality in smartphones
without aluminum unibody design and of
course my favorite the boomsound
front-facing speakers which were dope as
usual so you can expect the next HTC One
m9 to keep a lot of what made the HTC
One m8 so good and so popular like the
metal and like the boomsound
front-facing speakers so here's a
question with phones getting so much
bigger and screens getting huge and all
these smartphones we see can you make
this screen on this smartphone bigger
without making the whole phone huge see
the thing about the HTC One is it's
already a pretty big 5-inch screen and
then you add those huge speakers up top
and on the bottom so it's pretty large
and the power button up top has always
been a little bit hard to reach I guess
especially if you have small hands well
to answer this question we actually have
thanks to some pretty trustworthy
looking leaks a super clear look at the
HTC One m-9s design so right off the bat
you're gonna notice yep it's still metal
that all aluminum unibody enclosure is
still there and you also notice the
buttons are moved around so the volume
buttons are now moved over to the
right-hand side of the device and are
now separated and the power button is
now also moved from the top also to the
right hand side so all the buttons are
on the right-hand side of the device
which I guess should make them easier to
reach and a little bit easier to use
with one hand especially since this
phone will still be a little bit
slippery with that rounded metal so
aside from the back of the phone
those button changes seem to be the
biggest design change between the One m8
and the m9 this year which I guess is a
good thing if you already like the
current design which a lot of people did
so a lot of the complaints about the HTC
One have been about its camera this
camera actually it's one of the most
polarizing cameras in all of smartphones
because some people really love it but a
lot of people are just really
disappointed by it and are torn over
buying a phone like this because it
seems like the biggest weakness
the HTC One m7 the first generation when
it first came out had this ultra pixel
camera so four megapixels which is
supposed to be better in low-light this
optical image stabilization did really
well but overall the photos and videos
it took were pretty meh they weren't
always spectacular a lot of times people
did get great results but it was super
hit or miss so the HTC One m8 came out
and they stuck with the ultra pixels so
you get again get a four megapixel
sensor in here no 4k video but they made
it a little bit better and if you're
gonna stick with ultra pixels you have
to make it better
but again it wasn't blowing anything
else off the water it was again kind of
meh even though it was improved so the
HTC One m9 again according to these
leaks that Phandroid got ahold of is
looking to have a 20 megapixel camera so
goodbye ultrapixels no more it was a
nice run but things weren't exactly
clicking so 20.7 megapixels it's likely
looking to be one of those same sony
sensors that we've seen in the sony
xperia series capable of producing
extremely nice-looking photos and videos
and 4k videos now of course - obviously
it's a really high megapixel number and
they don't have to go all the way to the
other extreme with it I personally would
have liked this seen maybe an 8
megapixel larger sensor that still has
big pixels but I'm ok with them going
full on 20 megapixels hopefully it's
really really good and I'm looking
forward to seeing what kind of results
you get out of it a lot of people have
also mentioned it's not the prettiest
camera module in the world on the back
of that phone but then again neither was
the HTC One m8 that's not pretty either
and smartphone cameras in general don't
look that good on the back although you
know it doesn't really matter all that
much I just kind of want the pictures to
look good so with these new design
improvements basically button
improvements and the new Snapdragon 810
or 805 chip both really good three
gigabytes of RAM a 2840 milliamp hour
battery a Android 5.0 lollipop with
hopefully a light version of HTC Sense
on it and another five inch display
probably 1080p maybe quad HD but
probably not overall this is shaping up
to be a really impressive looking phone
and one of the most anticipated of 2015
like I said at the beginning might not
be changing a whole lot in the way of
design but
if it ain't broke don't fix it and we've
mentioned a lot that these big speakers
make the phone particularly hard to
handle if you're trying to reach the top
of the bottom so the buttons moving is a
good thing and they might even have a
little bit of room to make the display a
little bit bigger the Leake said it's
going to be another 5-inch 1080p display
that's the same as the current phone but
I'm thinking it may may get a little bit
larger five point one to five point two
but I wouldn't be surprised to see them
omit quad HD in favor of better battery
life so either way I'll be sure to get
my hands on this phone sooner or later
it's actually supposed to come out very
soon they always tend to launch early
spring around March so we should
alleviate all these rumors very soon if
it is slippery again I will be putting
the skin on the back of it like I have
with other slippery metal phones but let
me know what you guys think of this
phone in the comment section below and
we can chat about one m9 all day thanks
for watching and I'll talk to you guys
in the next one peace
[Music]